do you
see their way of achieving
testing that's verified but does not
violate people's privacy or sense of
freedom absolutely i i think so the way
that
right now in the united states they're
requesting that
these tests get
that the results get delivered to public
health agencies but i've long held that
while that's ideal it should never be
the thing that holds up somebody being
allowed to know their own status
but if you are going to work
and you have to let your boss or your
manager whomever know that you were
negative that day or if you're going to
school
i think it's going to be hard to
maintain complete privacy
in that situation because they need to
know your name but sure i mean could you
cut off the public health reporting
yes you could but i worry i mean can you
opt out maybe you could opt out that
should be a feature
i want to opt out of the public health
reporting because
for whatever reason otherwise i'm not
going to do the test and but that means
that okay then you're not going to go to
work so right now there's this serious
tension and
i am very uncomfortable with
the idea that we force anyone to do
anything but
there is a tension between these two
things for sure and how do you balance
that during a public health
emergency
i think first and foremost let people
everyone has a right to know their
status
the fact that we have made it hard for
people to know their status on their
terms i think is a
travesty i mean it's just so
terrible that we have
prioritized
us knowing at the expense of you know
essentially what like elta's long said
during this pandemic is
if i'm public health it's if i can't
know then you can't know your status
like that's not the right way to look at
public health we need to engage the
public and if some of them don't want to
participate in the public health part
but want to know
their status
by default they are participating in
public health whether they know it or
not because they're not going to go get
their mom sick by mistake
at least most people wouldn't and then
also you can create systems where
you can
individuals can form relationships based
on their status
without ever reporting it to a
centralized place so
you can go to i don't know
a local business owner might
require that you show
that you're negative
but that doesn't require reporting it
you can
like there might be um basically like an
id
that's only in possession you are the
only person in possession of that so you
literally show it exactly here's the
test i took it's negative and nobody
else knows about that test so that could
very well be done even through a company
like emed i think and i might be wrong
here
i believe that they take the test result
and because they are considered a clia
waived laboratory like a digital
laboratory
they report their results by law out to
uh the public health agencies
but let's say there was something a
little different let's say you were
verifying an over-the-counter test
and it doesn't have to be a clia wave
because it's over the counter then
you're not bound by clio rules
and
you could create the same service but
that just doesn't report out to the
public health agencies it gives people
the option
to opt in or out of public health
reporting and
you know
i know that public health people
get a little queasy when i talk about
this but
as a public health person myself like
yes of course i would prefer that the
data be available to evaluate to know
where the cases are
but first and foremost i want to make
sure that the people using the test
are are going to use the test and if
that means that they're not
reporting and if that's the only way
that they will use it is if it's not
reported then that's better than no test
especially given that the
central to the vaccine hesitancy is a
distrust of authority in the distrust of
government so
you're asking
you're asking people to get tested
uh and report their
status
to a centralized authority when they're
clearly
do not trust that authority it doesn't
make any sense it seems like a perfect
solution
to let people who are hesitant on the
vaccine
to uh
get their own status and have full
control of that information and opt-in
provide that information if they wish to
but they have the full control of it
they have the freedom to do that
information what they want i fully agree
with that i i really do i think we can
have the verified services
and we could have the privacy if you
want if you want if you need to go into
a restaurant and there's a rule that you
have to be a negative test
have it on your phone and only your
phone and it's okay like emed emails you
the the lab report you have it you can
say look that's my name i use it this
morning
negative
and in that case you'd want something
that just is there and is not
going anywhere else
you